in our morning rounds a new approach to
fighting multiple sclerosis the disease
where the body attacks its own central
nervous system ms affects about 400,000
people in the u.s. it is two to three
times more common among women current
treatments may have severe side effects
and there is no cure our doctor Tara
Narula shows us a cutting-edge but low
tech attempt to slow the symptoms good
morning good morning it involves the
diet and the microbiome bacteria that
live mostly in our digestive tract
unique to us as a fingerprint research
now underway at New York's Mount Sinai
Hospital is studying how food might be
used as medicine to combat the disease
we'll just go around and hear an update
from everyone once a month this
pioneering group of MS patients meets to
get tips from a nutritionist when grains
are refined they're stripped of this
outer layer and share their temptations
it was creamy hamburgers I'm terrible
the other day they had lobster crabs and
there was just no way I was gonna pass
that off neurologists Elana Katz and is
leading one of the first clinical trials
to study the link between what we eat
gut bacteria and MS symptoms why did you
decide to investigate diet and it's
linked to ms the gut is actually kind of
a natural place to look and that's
because the immune system about 70% of
it lives inside the gut and has
far-reaching implications throughout the
rest of the body in ms inflammation
occurs when immune cells attack the
brain and spinal cord
this study is testing whether a dietary
intervention can reprogram the immune
system to slow down the assault on
itself so this right here is a very
typical look
spot her in this Kareem Providence and
the other patients enrolled in the trial
are following a strict Mediterranean
style diet no processed food dairy or
meat but lots of fruits vegetables and
whole grains why did you choose that
type of diet we think that those are
anti-inflammatory we also think that
they're neuro protective symptoms like
fatigue difficulty walking vision
problems and cognitive changes can be
severe and disabling but it can take a
very heavy toll on patients I was really
fearful because you don't have a family
have my children I have my husband and I
felt like as if my life would just be
over with the help of medication Kareem
is still able to work nights as an
oncology nurse four years after her
diagnosis have a pleasant day for her
sticking to the diet is a small
sacrifice for better health no
chocolate-chip cookies no dairy no
vanilla ice cream that I love so much
but I mean if I can participate in a
diet that can change my life
give me a longevity give me a piece of
how I was before I don't mind this is a
small study of about 30 it will be six
months before researchers know if the
diet has any measurable impact on MS
symptoms though some in the group
already report more energy researchers
are also looking at quality of life
blood pressure cholesterol and weight
loss all right another reason greens are
a good thing well but a world with no
chocolate chip cookie I don't know dr.
Turner thank you thank you very much bro
would you eat you are what you eat
indeed